el primer ministro en landro modi
anunció el viernes que su gobierno
derogaría a las tres leyes agrícolas
aprobadas por el parlamento hace un año
leyes que han provocado protestas
masivas de los sindicatos de
agricultores en varios estados el
anuncio sorpresa marca un cambio de
dirección importante ya que el gobierno
no había tomado ninguna iniciativa para
hablar con los agricultores en los
últimos meses la medida se produce el
día del festival de grupo cuando se
celebra el cumpleaños del fundador del
sijismo gurú nanak principalmente el
pasado miles de agricultores de los
estados norteños de haryana y punjab
habían acampado en las fronteras de
delhi desde noviembre pasado y decenas
murieron de calor frío y kobe uno de los
mayores cambios de las tres leyes fue
que se permitió a los agricultores
vender sus productos a un precio de
mercado directamente a empresas
agrícolas cadenas de supermercados y
tiendas de comestibles en línea la
mayoría de los agricultores indios
venden actualmente sus productos a
mercados mayoristas controlados por el
gobierno a precios mínimos asegurados
las leyes permitían a los compradores
privados a acumular alimentos como arroz
trigo y legumbres
las ventas lo que solo podían hacer
antes los agentes autorizados por el
gobierno el procedimiento para revertir
las leyes se llevaría a cabo durante la
sesión de invierno del parlamento que
comienza la próxima semana informó el
primer ministro